We've seen the basic first sub
command for frame called variable.
But LODB's frame command
can do much more than this.
To demonstrate on back
in the semi bug zap,
and were paused at the handle single
tap method that we've seen before.
And this is in the break
point bug view controller.
>From the console,
we can look up information about LLDB
commands including frame,
by typing Help.
So I'll delete this and
type Help and I'll just go ahead and
scroll through all this, so
you can see the entire output.
We have all the commands and
then there are command abbreviations.
Like the FR and
the V that we saw earlier.
That you can see for
the different commands.
And I'll stop here for a frame.
And here's the information we have.
It says that frame provides
a set of commands for
operating on the current
thread's frames.
And by frames, it means stack frames.
So to get more specific help
information about frame,
I can type the command
frame followed by help.
This delete button clears
out the console, by the way.
So that's what I clicked to do that.
We'll go frame help.
And now we can see that frame
supports the following subcommands.
So there's the variable command
that we used earlier, but
it also supports info and select.
And at the bottom, it says, for help on
any particular subcommand we can type
help command and then the subcommand.
So for example, help frame variable,
should give us the help information
about the variable subcommand.
Well we've already seen
the variable subcommand, so
I want to try the two others.
So I've stopped the application, and
I've kind of reset up our
debugging environment here.
I've set a breakpoint at
the add bug to view method.
And there are no other breakpoints
in the particular app.
And this is for
the BreakpointBugViewController.
And I've triggered this breakpoint
again by just tapping on the screen.
So let's type, frame info.
And we could see that the output shows
that the current frame is frame zero,
and this is for the addBugToView method.
And this mirrors what we have in the
debug navigator, which is frame zero,
and frame zero is for
the add bug to view method.
And to switch the current stack frame,
we can use the frame select
subcommand followed by a frame number,
so I'll select frame one.
And just like that, Xcode jumps us
to stack frame one, which is for
handleSingleTap, here.
And you can see that it's jumped
us here in the code area as well.
And this is pretty neat.
It's not really that much different than
what we can achieve by just clicking
around in the debug navigator,
which you can do the same thing
here in the console,
by just selecting different frames.
So now it's really unleashed
the power of the command line,
to do something that you can't
already do in the graphical interface.
And we'll do this with
the expression command.
The expression command,
let's us run swift expressions in
the current debugging context.
So this is actually really cool.
This means,
we can do things like run methods.
Or even change the values of variables
while our program is paused.
So I'll start typing the command expr,
which is an abbreviation for
expression, followed by println.
And bugs, so
this is just like the println statement
that we could put in our code.
You can see that
currently bugs is empty.
So I'll go ahead and
just continue a couple times, so
that bugs contains some things.
And actually, I'll turn this off,
this breakpoint off, hit play so
it runs all the way through.
We should have way to many bugs now.
Turn the breakpoint back on.
I'll reach again.
Let's run the same expression.
And see the our bugs array is very full,
now that we have all those extra bugs,
that have been created.
So that first expression for
just printing, that's pretty cool.
But let's try something
a little bit more fun.
We can actually empty the bugs array.
So to do this, we'll use
expression self.bugs.removeAll.
And this takes a argument, keepCapacity.
And we'll specify this is true and
we'll hit enter.
And now when I run this expression,
it appears that it's completed, but
we don't see any updates visually,
if we go back to the simulator
there's nothing here.
This makes sense because we're
paused at the breakpoint, after all.
Because we're paused, none of these
changes have taken effect, but
if the expression did run
we could quickly check
while we're paused by printing
the bug's array again.
And we can see that it's now empty.
And if we were to step over,
we'll see that we drop right into the if
statement, which also further validates
that the bugs count is now zero,
or the bugs array is empty.
And that is less than the maximum bugs,
so now we're dropping right
back into that if statement.
So we were able to change
things on the fly to
alter the execution of our program.
That's pretty cool.
And I'll hit play and
continue back and there you go.
More bugs are created.